foreign
week of college and I'm already in my
back transition's gone smooth and I've
already met some interesting new people
that's right junior is returning to Zoe
University now Marcus this is a big deal
like this is your first season as the
Big Man on Campus the main character the
narrator I know we were excited for it
but I gotta ask Trevor and Dave how did
your mans do how did you manage to do as
the lead guy he's been amazing since
I've met him since I've seen him on TV
since he was very young he's always a
great grounded natural actor and so he's
only going to get better from that time
your card was declined I was wondering
if you could loan me some cash how did
you go from having an apartment and
owning your own air fryer to asking me
for money this is going to spread
through the family tax chain like
wildfire I think on blackish it was a
very different experience getting to see
it but it was a great learning
experience getting to see Anthony and
how he operated leading the show and and
and the confidence that he brought to
set and the way that he inspired the
rest of us
um and it was always exciting but it was
a lot to live up to and then you know
way Yara transitioned over to gronish
and I was very excited to be able to to
take the reins I'm not going to tell you
how to do college but focus on the
things
exciting to see
the CEOs from your brackish family on
the show as well is there anyone in
particular that you want to have on that
we haven't seen yet oh man I'd love to
have Jennifer Lewis on the show either
her or Lawrence together would be
hilarious
um and we don't I know just be create
the craziest moments even just passing
by her yeah something's gonna happen
it's something she's always ready she's
always ready Junior it's not it maybe I
have outgrown it maybe you have Dre oh